three
three balm lemon tree very pretty and
the lemon flower is sweet but the
fruit of the lemon is impossible to
these welcome back to threesome episode five
i believe is number five is a
lie
yeah love our currencies and yeah and
this is ah blah blah blah spit
it out look i'm fun nervous i've
never talked to this many people before
no jackie wolff little jackie paper
what time everyone wake up today okay
okay okay let's go let's down
are you sure you want to do
this
because i'll tell you what to i
woke up this i slept through the
night oh is eating solid food yeah
to be clean took a little kooky
you know five five thirty eight okay
oh yeah wow i mean i went
to bed at ten
still so not horrible idea that's didn't
didn't feel like an app today maybe
because of all the memes i've eaten
but yeah yeah what about you laura
this is lauren lucas mascot aka tomkins
is over there okay at lauren's going
to tell us that what time she
woke up in the morning eight and
let my cat drink out of the
tub and wide wait huh yeah i
was already able to lick the faucet
do you turn it on a little
bit hard on this oh i see
so i got up and you know
peed and let her do that and
then i turned it off and got
back in bed and i slept until
eleven because i had nothing to do
this morning and i was like i'm
going to re
only sleep in at the time did
you go to bed um
twelve thirty probably that's so a lot
of sleep i loved it and i
um you know have this rain machine
that i mentioned and i'm telling you
that really takes me right back to
sleep but i'll just be like it's
raining and i'll just fall right back
asleep because i also can't hear my
neighbor who makes money my neighbors make
a lot of noise
like a truck pulling it out of
the driveway all the time and just
a truck like shouting out the address
that they're going to would like what
address are they shouting um like hey
pull into oh no you know doesn't
do that even though it's very common
but ah they have like a gate
that they drive over to coat chill
and like it just like makes this
noise and you know not all day
there's a fee
do people who live in this model
a string of buildings kind of thing
anyways was super loud too but the
ray machine has completely stopped me from
hearing them when i was like why
didn't i do this ray machines you
wasted how many years of your life
years it's sad to think about um
we ah my janey bought us the
time
what time did you wake up in
jail god and so ravishing you got
me i was trying to evade the
question you gotta ny haven't slept in
three days oh no oh hey yeah
i'm running on fumes right now wow
i shouldn't have driven here wow um
what time i wake up today i
think i woke up at eight o'clock
today and i laid in bed for
a little bit do you yeah i
was gonna say you get up and
do it
five thirty are you getting up and
you're like well guess my coffee you
know yeah so i wake up and
i say usually when i wake up
there's a conversation with myself like is
this one of those instances where i
can go back to sleep like either
read for a second and then go
back to sleep and if i'm like
no my brain is too busy then
i get up i
i read emails every the news i
make coffee i do all that kinda
stuff and that's usually that's usually the
case if it's you know one or
two or three thirty in the morning
that's usually like okay i can be
up for one or two hours and
then go back to sleep for another
couple i mean it's sleek clutch
so busy oh okay
wait what thirty or like wow i
don't have to start my day now
i guess i think i'll allow myself
to be awake for an hour they're
very occasionally if i wake up at
one thirty and my brain is going
i can get back to sleep but
usually if my brain is going on
like look i'm going to be up
for a couple hours so let me
just like get off the work
first watch tv or read or or
do some work or something like that
and then i'll then i'll go back
to sleep at four or five or
so like yeah this is yeah nine
ten eleven twelve ah wow ah i
sorta think they're sucking stop that i
wanna just
ah
oh popeye
who was gonna say what what is
it say here is kind of like
you were gonna say i was gonna
say when i like i it's incredibly
rare for me to wake up and
be able to focus sleep i don't
have a problem sleeping button i kind
of like the
idea of getting up and like starting
my day though you're describing like i'll
just check in with things and get
it going and maybe exercise or that's
because you're saying like in the in
the middle of the night know like
you're saying in the wake up early
in the morning by thirty or so
yeah yes for a hot minute this
summer i was right yes yeah
yeah but i was right i was
writing that early and it was great
i would like that's very impressed get
up right first thing for like three
or four hours go out on the
patio or something like that when the
sun was coming up wow and just
and and everything's quiet and there's nothing
to do but just like you know
put and and the thing is is
the night before i would i would
have
put the writing down and would be
thinking about story problems as i was
going to bed and sometimes i would
dream like solutions and stuff like that
and then you'd like get up and
you just you gotta get him down
but then um i like to write
at the movies i will take my
laptop to like siskel and ebert and
wait yes like transit i wanted anymore
i will say like well just give
getting any ideas i had a dream
last night and i know it's really
boring explaining what your dream was i'm
not gonna try to but my dream
is that it always is i just
agree with that someone once said that
like i think it's an a play
that hearing about people's experiences in vietnam
is a lot like listening to their
dreams like it's so foreign
that it's just fearing to listen to
missive that's what i don't know i
read that one wow let's see if
this bores you i had a dream
last night that was so amazing idea
and might have even been when i
fell back asleep this data tree video
but i do i went to a
museum dream about museums lady yeah and
my dream i got to go to
london i was running through an airport
no money masks up to seventy and
i was kind of scared but i
was also excited i was going and
then i um went to a museum
and the museum had this really beautiful
exhibit that was just
just astounding and i was it was
all these giant colorful animals i don't
know how to explain it i can't
explain it and maybe it was something
you were meant to do when the
dream i said to somebody it was
like seeing a color you've never seen
before there's no way for me to
explain this to you it was so
amazing and mike said if you're a
painter it feels like this would be
like the thing you are going gonna
paint that everyone but
wow she's yeah and i was like
then i got sad
because you forgot it or because they
had no way to execute
right maybe when it was cool maybe
you're meant to genetically engineer animals okay
i think you're right purple giraffe anyone
i love
hey lauren them you get a purple
era anyway but it was so amazing
and i feel like my dreams now
where nobody's wearing masks i feel stressed
but i also feel excited like i'm
doing things in the world in my
dreams lot and it's so sad to
wake up and be like wow i
know i'm stuck here or anything i've
only had one dream so far where
the masks were involved really yeah we're
that had not i mean probably subconsciously
in some symbolic way i'm sure this
is entered my dream school because my
dreams over your mowing
huh every room i haven't been a
hospital bed i can't breathe ventilator but
the other night i headed by i
had my first dream where yeah it
although around me are familiar faces worn
out places listed tray sit in a
little loop
i forgot the helicopter song hello cup
wasn't nobody guys it anyway nobody knows
what he's trying to find somebody who's
looking uzi look at ziba guys look
at this
and to be clear it was ten
minutes ago that we came up with
yes yes for you it was last
week for us it was earlier today
and when i say earlier i mean
it's good to go so wait so
your dream you had a dream with
a mask i had a dream um
did somebody saying you had a big
dream so i was i remember i
was smoking
ny i want do you want to
continue and no i forfeit my time
yeah i know i get to kick
my toe stories over i don't know
where i was so i oversaw all
masks maybe symbolically their way but i've
had crazy dreams and it's been
i kind of enjoyable yeah i tried
and i hung out with some friends
some mutual friends of ours and i
was like because i become mutuals i
haven't gotten to see them in nearly
seven months and i woke up going
well that was nice to spend time
with him should i tell them i
dreamed about hanging out with them like
would that make them feel like oh
that's cool like we hung out together
and i thought no it's just weird
that the take a text like that
and go well i'm trying to take
a man i had so i had
two dreams about someone who is not
in my life anymore and not out
of any sort of awe to say
goodbye true i used to do not
out of any falling out or anything
like that we just
together and then when we stopped working
together we sort of just wasn't right
yeah she talks to them and you're
like fuck you i never want to
talk to a guy i know because
of the word i have not texted
him but the dream was very vivid
and it was very bittersweet and so
i had the i the first dream
like those toffee m and m's you
why
i was having such a nice time
i feel like dreams can really be
but it made me want to write
to that person and say yeah say
hey we get back in touch yeah
yeah now i think you're going to
do think they would be why do
you think they would receive it i
think that i'm going to because i
keep thinking about it and it's been
like a week yeah and
and i had another dream where she
was ah she tommy was boo
did she wove
so my dreamscape like ah i don't
even know what that was ah yeah
um that's the universe trying to tell
you something my men is it the
universe or is it my own brain
transforming something you know i narrow it
down i feel like reaching back out
to people such to such a risk
it's hard i had a friend i
think this person will receive it well
well disciplined interrupt you
ah the shock yeah oh no i
only
this is what it feels like when
doves cry
touch if you like stuff
touch you won't touch if you will
my stomach might well make filo trembles
inside pose that my what do you
think it was dvds
my dvds
what if he was saying dvds touch
if you will my baby look if
anyone was going to do it it
would be lauren that's not a good
angle for me you don't know that
i have one good angle which is
straight on neck up and that's it
oh good yes i get all nice
you know
you're talking about trying to cover my
body show you get to take this
picture find i had a friend that
you know paul ah who shall remain
nameless who's smart who said that yes
of course who says it all the
more valuable you always need to check
back in and with time wreck back
yes at the time
there were no emails but i reckon
what he said he said call your
friends if if if it gets to
be six months and you haven't called
or i guess now emailed or texted
one of your friends then you will
lose that friendship so always try my
dad is that true do so much
trail do some sort of like hey
i was just think
alright guys you have to say i
feel like the pandemic is has different
rules because we've all lost touch and
time is passing so hey time is
passing so any rangeley that like a
month passes in a blink of an
eye and i would not have gotten
in touch with anyone and i'm like
it feels like it's like hey we
all know
we can't see each other so let's
all just be incommunicado you know i
should have a lot of chatter we
never met i a lot of touch
with but a lot of people that
i haven't really connected with and i
feel like it's fine i don't think
it's like a sign that like we
won't be fred it is interesting we
we we are on a few text
chains together yeah and those they they
used to be sort of like
like directed at a certain type of
text but now it's just like anything
that's happening yeah like gets put into
those text threads because it's like we
need friends we have no one to
talk to yeah yeah i know what
about this thing that happened to all
of us it is nice even with
the texting today i asked about something
about voting like which president chae vote
for and stuff
super helpful which of the two presidents
forty five president dewey was on kanye
was alright as vice president his vice
rose i so you didn't want to
be present that it was a whole
president campaign vice president to whom some
guy name rocky oh rocky balboa yeah
yeah for my old dog there were
two people who had nicknames one was
rocky and quotes and almost spike in
quote i gotta say if it was
my old dog i
would vote for look what i was
shot five with snoopy's brother lives in
arizona by go for him too yeah
but weren't you surprised to open the
ballot and see that there were like
ten different people i was like yeah
hey i thought truly i always think
there's like one more president whoa that's
the thing is president shouldn't be a
binary choice hey guys vote
eating is over already if we know
as voted by damier la raza time
marine by the ten year labor zona
know who the president is going to
be sworn in january and then have
special knowledge that we don't have until
the same time you have it right
we don't technically know that maybe like
we're we're we're we're taping this in
advance
nsw of the election we don't know
whether the court case let's not talk
anyway yeah let's talk about some dumb
shit that we talk about thumb sheehy
i say my jam shit yeah sorry
my dumb shit yeah who's a dumb
shit that you know paul oh i
know a bunch of dumb shits let
me tell you some of those govern
my old neighbor ah johnny thumb
shall we call a low-water water what
is like um what type of music
or listen to it we are what
who's a new artist who can i
tell you something is that i don't
listen to my music listening you know
doe ray me fah sollecito i love
to listen to i love i love
the notes get along yeah i loved
hear the notes because they're so familiar
yes
i anytime i listen to a song
like i don't like this order of
the notes and i go back and
listen to the notes in order yeah
i love it you know bass clef
treble clef i listened yeah yeah okay
i was gonna try so many podcasts
oh you don't listen to music okay
why i don't listen to podcast last
year's top three podcasts are listening to
right now right
oh my guy oh oh my
guy this has been our promo it's
alright my lasagna harder listen i wasn't
just a phone
um let me look at my podcast
list as far as music goes lauren
i have an artist i would like
to introduce to you greatly can i
wish you would you could play it
on the on the thing let me
just find the title the artist there's
a specific song ah yeah there's a
few but valerie june is the artist
and the tune that i like specifically
astral plane is astral plane do you
know it no that came up on
the parquet robot alright let's hear a
little astro plane by valerie june let
it get to the chorus
maybe
boo
you haven't sigh
oh
oh la la
kanno shah
so
does she mean mirror
i love sigh
snow leave stay
don't rush just listen the day when
you freaking are these directions shut up
just listen to the song yeah
dancing on the ass
oh no of planes
london fans
ramey cso
yes
hi to shy
uh oh we get it music
get to rub our faces in itch
isn't it pretty it is pretty nice
fucking kids nowadays valerie june you got
what it takes oh joy you made
my list i really love that whole
album and where did you first hear
it in on an episode of grey's
anatomy know is that oh no i'm
just assuming um no but
thank you um no i'm on a
chama tech chain with a few friends
and we send songs primarily oh and
that song was introduced to me why
are these specific people ah the ones
sending songs to each other that just
kind of people are music for free
we all we tend to like the
same music
but we also did fall liked it
glad i'm glad he's giving it up
for one of mine ah yeah and
then i have another friend way or
ten songs shoe as well and she
sends me a lot of great songs
and i like that way of keeping
in touch because it's kind of nice
it's like you don't really say anything
it's like here
don't have here some mood like like
i had a you know i gave
people a prompt like i dare you
to start your day with the song
tomorrow you know and it was tina
turner simply the best chances have a
good day started off no matter what
your mood just put it on i
let me say two things i am
on a textured like that that's dormant
right now but i wanted to restart
it with tawny newsome
and our old friend producers zig remember
zig found one of the family members
of the pretzel gang i remember zig
yeah only looking at his tweets all
day but we would we would share
sort of um obscure songs with each
other and it was really fun i
really liked a lot ah but also
the simply the best song to play
huh i didn't realize how nice the
lyrics were until ah shits creek where
somebody did ah oh ah so um
acoustic cover of it oh cool and
i was like this is a nice
song there is no ideally nice yeah
there's a tina turner version of it
which is good this is a song
that someone sent to me that i
thought was really ah pretty that i
will have the
oh now like an add everyone i
hate that oh this song stinks this
is a bad song we talking
a
i'm gonna give you another sober yes
um ok it will mainly find it
um i let's see did the song
kiss can't do much by waxahachie a
familiar yeah yeah
can't do much i wasn't looking in
that sounds like scott had run away
yeah call you over she'll flash into
the pool this is waxahachie with can't
do much
on kiss fm
three m radio
i wish we had a radio
station i would prefer just playing music
to doing puckett veto
na was born
nice
mama turns to something useless to try
easy knicks too
has there ever been a song where
the verses better than the chorus never
you know what i mean like you're
always like wait for the chorus because
that's a good part but zara which
is like holy shit this verse is
so good and then the chorus comes
in and it's just white cars by
gary numan hey i ran my car
yeah i don't drive very far
and i don't have to fart
waxahachie you got what it takes we
love what you've been down we're picking
it up by her song the other
day i say again you get kitchen
a day scott got his dog for
you do i said this to you
but to me this time it up
to the bike just tell me
sure trouble in bide by the carolina
chocolate drops
trouble in your mind your mom specifically
live at katie
paychecks
here we go twenty nine o nine
it's in high definition well i will
say that this is the first one
that came up so hopefully it is
the correct one
is this your cult meeting mo
i dared them to start their day
this way
don't get troubling
there you go and that's the course
see now they know it as we
go along sort of just you know
there's no no song goes house dog
show
oh
uh will take your parker side-by-side oh
no he's having a slash bag
i don't want to ask her she
looks rude shui meka three m spotify
playlist yeah yea that's just fun that's
fun that seems cool i like that
i've never heard of that band the
carolina chocolate ventilation dallas helicopter uzi le
z luck and z
luck in far
yeah we did it yeah we certainly
did do it is yet to take
a break wait what
you want to take a break whoa
i thought we had to we have
to become easy almost eminence to just
twenty five minutes into the you were
thinking of every day we are gonna
have a guest layer on we are
gonna guess it's it's tony hale
yeah it jumps out of the pool
does he live nearby no i don't
think ya i would let tony hale
a delight of any tie shadow stevens
last time i saw tony hale i
was with you where were we at
dj's play cuts rye game to see
jamie's play my wife is an actor
i visited my when
probably yeah it must have been i
think that tony windex a long time
ago that you wouldn't have seen tony
yeah well it was a while ago
i mean when machine that poe was
oh it was when the movie came
you saw tony really yeah so so
a year and a year ago a
year ago yeah alright i don't know
if he came out a uv came
a penis gets her
heard at thirteen
you can't make that a thing
right
it already became a thing in-between last
episode this guy me i'm just capitalizing
on all bw right oh you mean
online yeah we're taking a break goodbye
we're back we are back and you
know what time it is on our
last episode of three of them poor
through threesome we had the eminem challenge
where we tasted seven types of memes
and now our tummies hurt yeah they
feel bad and sick we do six
more
that's right we went from feeling elated
to feeling tired to feeling sick well
i it's i eat more candy my
belief is that we should end with
these brownies because these brown ones because
this is going to take over all
flavor pow oh really i was thinking
start with them because they're clearly going
to be the worst they are but
i mean i think that's gonna ruin
the alright i think that's a good
that's a good point yeah
yeah wait a minute okay yeah got
it so wait a minute let me
explain what i mean let me i
was all talk i wanna talk to
and i think for all targets time
this is the way it goes um
on our last episode we tasted seven
types of eminem's and we picked our
top three flavors i mean our tasting
six other types were gonna pick our
top three
and then those six will go up
against each other head-to-head next week with
possibly the addition of crispy possibly we
can get our hands on some crispy
we're definitely going to do it and
we will tell you what the flavors
are as we eat them paul do
you want to kick it off should
we start with pretzel that's a nice
one i love pretzel really you guys
have had pretzel before oh yeah you
also make lousy house pets ah
alright we're gonna eat these the problem
we're gonna tell you what we think
the problem with pretzels the pretzels always
feel stale but i still keep going
do i mean
huh i like the combo but i
know what you mean about the pretzels
like it's not the freshest tasting at
the end of it i'm kinda like
oh it felt hollow
like life yeah the hollow man in
theaters now it brought it back
no one can go oh no pretty
good yeah um okay it's okay next
up hazelnut now hazelnut hazelnut why it's
like nutella exactly
hazelnut looks a little like the peanut
butter in size they're not quite as
big as almond oh
oh
i don't think i liked that very
much it's a little like the toffee
oh god well bit ooh it's almost
as a fruit flavor to it little
bitter medicinal to me yeah
yeah that's sucked i'd want toothpaste yeah
i'd want i didn't like it okay
spoiler alert probably not going to end
up in our top three alright what's
next don't jump ahead you never know
when we go to dark choco la
nice little palate cleanser guys like dark
chocolate i feel like i liked our
chocolate in general i don't know why
i love it
wow
i like a dark chocolate i'll go
wow i feel like if you're getting
these taste like regular if you're good
no we're getting dark chocolate it's like
no healthier thing more bitter nova getting
an m a number of it a
dozen yeah i would say a dark
chocolate um
is probably just as many calories as
a regular right
i didn't like that i think it's
okay
alright what's next it also tastes like
nothing to me tasted yeah i think
we should go almond then meant then
coffee yes okay yeah alright next up
is almond these look a lot like
the peanut i mean i can't lie
they look a lot like peanut
an almond is a nut so i'm
skeptical it makes sense when you think
about it i don't like it
it's got a lot of nutty flavor
it's more nutty than liking life
but there's more no you're not
okay
do what a bidder
oh yeah what was that oh helicopter
they start to bizarre law and he's
like a bizarre law is like a
bizarre mwah yeah that might have been
the original song there might have been
and it came to all of us
just anybody want a peanut is from
that young baby like ah mandy patinkin
movie princess bride
yes it was andre the giant one
of those earliest screen roles certainly my
giant was based on his friendship with
billy crystal
but they got a different giant i
think so because he was dead right
oh hello what yeah under your eyes
just hearing the me is one of
his policy this isn't meant dark chocolate
and dark chocolate so if we didn't
like the dark chocolate well we like
it with mint let's see
yeah like gum franco's
it's like gum these remind me of
a certain mince you would get at
restaurants yeah oh it's very very minty
not as good i think
i like it though i don't i
don't hate it but what i buy
it you know it's like oh what
am i eating this after a steak
it's like marriage you know i'm saying
what i won't say it but i'll
buy it or well it's nice to
have companionship but i don't wanna live
forever why fuck now i'm honestly afraid
of this life oh no this is
gonna suck alright this is coffee
you know there's no way this is
gonna be good i know in my
heart
oh
oh yeah we have the wildest flavors
though they're all competing against each other
i think we need to have like
two or three shit
and you know what should taste like
because i've eaten everyone knows everyone didn't
shit
does admit it look
you shit heads out there hey jude
edge that was that was just recolor
listeners chickens
they don't have a say in it
that was really not good well this
is gonna be hard
to pick our three favorites from this
bunch oh yeah the smoke from this
bunch all your yea oh god yeah
okay all right and everyone pick your
three oh i got him don't say
well don't say like what secret forever
yeah i've talked you know you don't
want to be influenced i don't want
to be influenced okay
i'm gonna write my older three in
your hand
okay alright everybody have their three got
him alright i my three in alphabetical
alphabetical got it all manned men to
dark chocolate pretzel my three in alphabetical
order are almond mint dark chocolate and
pretzel
whoa my three in alphabetical order are
almond
dark chocolate pretzel wait a minute in
the middle what did you say i
said i just cleared my throat and
said dark chocolate trick us into thinking
he said men so it's not meant
it's not meant dark charm i just
picked regular dive the menace to two
spearmen gummy for understanding it is it
is and that these should tell you
that
in high school and you hated it
that's right here come smear my name
spamming me it comes fair maccabi bouncy
account aha meals alright so are you
guys keeping track of your favorites so
you're logging them i took pictures okay
oh that's right pictures oh no i
gotta take a picture because i'm i
did something different okay yep you and
lauren had the same
favorite three from last time and you
and lauren have the same favorite three
from this time so i guess i've
got everyone's pictures covered except for two
of them okay i took a picture
mine
wow what an exciting development we found
that the crazier the flavor the less
we liked it a true roller coaster
in a candy coated shell you wouldn't
think that like just plain m and
m's would be so good and better
than oh no you need to add
something
why don't you take it from randoms
delete coffee from the website and delete
toffee nut who wants this you know
i went to the website they didn't
even have the fucking their newest flavor
you get this fraud was that sexy
green eminem oh yes she was maybe
i got distracted for a little boom
get the eminem i got them
i'm online from ah various places that
were so amazon i got an amazon
various places yeah that's what you say
when you don't want to say amazon
yeah yeah a various place we online
various places retailers and gents are you
on a scale of one to ten
being one being um not close at
all and ten being very close to
quitting amazon
one
z is there something less than one
i wish that were not the case
i wish they were not the case
well especially now it's just too i
think i think wishing it wasn't the
case is like your too
you know learned i'll fucking take it
and here is you're just gonna tell
me what my number is your zero
because you're like how else am i
supposed to get anything yeah i'm um
i'm a i'm a three i still
use it a lot but i feel
bad and i'm thinking about trying to
do it less and i sometimes will
seek out ah
if i find something i'll find it
on different websites i was doing that
really diligently for a while it's also
it is a lot of it is
fucking mental state where like it was
just easier you know one day like
what i but it's been sucks and
i'm looking for a weird thing i
need to get for what weird perk
apis for some fuckin kill doe doe
show
you saw that video they say yes
wait what oh we're idea for halloween
decorations video i was out of that
pug
no why no what were you thinking
dildo wouldn't know that i'm talking about
pug v washed out in the costume
i was oh my god that was
obviously that was the video till the
end okay what was it it was
a video i was scrolling through amazon
lynch grow when they see me scrolling
aid and um he's growling
when i was weird huh um
lydia oh
i was looking for halloween decorations and
so i'm looking for realistic looking um
ravens
and so he got put into the
search realistic raven i put realistic ravens
you can see it in the video
in the search bar oh it is
okay it's so any baltimore ravens stuff
come up or it was just no
looking for a realistic raven in a
football uniform can you come to my
house
should be on camera i want to
meet him
and so i'm scrolling down all these
different ravens ravens ravens nevermore nevermore marathon
and the very bottom fuckin to tilt
it was in related searches his largest
dildo was were they like the color
of a raven no they no they
sure were
worked wow
i don't want a house on it
was so jar it makes our job
you if you're amazon you don't want
dildo to ever come up in related
switch by the way anyone has never
come up with anything else i've ever
searched yeah things that you could see
where sure this would happen yeah but
did not yeah
but why are you so upset because
your operators are surprised that amazon sells
dildo are you so upset because you
already have a bunch and you like
why would they even think i need
this yeah like trying to stop trying
to show me the thing i already
bought amazon has everything that's it's crazy
that you can buy a dildo in
the same cart as you put in
a realistic raven yeah but it really
was
this is absolutely not the place to
put that it was so jarring especially
for halloween early children's kid you couldn't
cure his holiday that you will have
to be a joy joy i think
dill doe's shouldn't be a suggested search
i think you should have to know
what i just know you ok i
don't listen to what google dot corn
do you know what like you can
use if you start having a vagina
it isn't fill it in like there
are a lot of words that they
won't fill in well let's say like
veggies janeiro
but like it doesn't it'll fill in
like the weirdest things and then it
won't fill in like terms you might
want to learn about but that could
be perceived as like right pro-choice or
like something crazy right i hate everyone
i hate google dotcom i use
dot corp i use amazon but i
e bay all my groceries
retail i will never use really winning
yes the thrill of women and the
countdown when i when some grapes see
i buy groceries on amazon and then
i sell them oh yeah probably watch
breaking auction but yeah i think it
did
oh my goodness um alright we have
to take a break we'll be right
back with a three-tier that's so excitable
i have a police car song oh
boy
and we're back we are back the
pretzel gang you know we're in the
house wow look at those chem trails
look at the i gotta spray my
vinegar interesting that we all picked pretzel
in our last segment when we're the
press
zyl gang oh shit wow he's pretzel
gonna win there's no chance there's zero
chance have you have you guys had
the sharpies pretzels yet no i keep
meaning to order them and i forgot
because what is that and yeah we
talk a little company that started out
here that tall philly style pretzels someone
made beautiful soft pretzels someone made us
pizza
holes are something we had great pretzels
over here for a little while maybe
that was it yeah yeah over here
or in quarantine oh i mean over
here so you think you didn't hear
howtos christina picked him up yeah yeah
snow sharpies that's what you oh okay
so that's what we yeah ok yeah
and i have nappies that sharpies for
you yea nah sick boy yeah idea
that shabby
forget why jack is shutting down i'm
gonna get those i took gotta get
em but see here's what i get
i get i stopped my scared nervous
i get nervous because it's you have
to pick them up on a certain
day bubble blah and i'm like i
can't think that far ahead like i
feel like i'm gonna a time right
now my life where i'm like your
live for them sitting around in bed
till
eleven that was an except shop was
yesterday we were right my days feel
very busy in this way i don't
know yeah i feel like there was
there was this you know huge swath
of dead space for a while and
then all of a sudden everything got
extremely busy it's you know when cell
phones were firm
first invented yes i do ren deny
told you think i am ah aren't
you too yes some two years old
my friend and i say that you
were younger
because i wouldn't remember something to invented
my friend and i had ah had
an agreement we said like okay we're
not going to get him because and
this was our our theory was that
if you get a cell phone everyone
will always assume that you are reachable
all the time and then you'll have
to constantly be responding to things in
common fallacy of cell phones which it
well i mean
it it is a thing like i
think it's kind of true it's kind
of true that people assume that but
it's i was you to say no
i'm not right and i think i
do respond very quickly and i create
a loop where i'm like i but
it's weird if i don't respond when
i was gonna say though is that
the now being quarantined everyone now assumes
that you have no
and yes day so i don't like
that yeah so it feels it but
it just it feels like having a
cell phone when cell phones were invented
compounded now right now you have email
and you're supposedly just sitting around all
day now my positions i don't know
if you're facing this paul but like
why just because you don't want to
but the
they're like we need it by today
like it's like very like extremely you
know i have not you're just sitting
around your house taped right now i've
had a couple of couple of additions
but janie has had way more and
that and they are all last-minute they're
all like they're like here's twelve pages
how is due by nine a lie
isn't like that like get it on
my first of all there's no rush
zaydi pictures of spiderman people aren't rushing
back to soccer why do you need
it by tomorrow i know like it
all just bothered like no one's filming
anything right like why do you want
it's okay to you in six months
here's the other side of it though
i think with with just personal communication
and a little bit of professional communication
too with people asking you to do
shows or this or that is that
when people are slow to respond to
me i'm like oh they're going through
the same thing that i'm going through
where it's like yeah i can't get
it together to answer that email today
and then what happens is i just
think about it for days and days
and days and then it gets pushed
down i have this i have a
couple of those yeah i when when
we like kiva and i
i have always talked about like there's
nothing better than a quick know like
i love i'm good at that and
i know i came to say like
if someone asked you to show and
i'm like i know i won't feel
like doing this but it's just like
sometimes you have to wrestle with it
and go like do i feel like
doing this for like six hours before
you can really like i am open
but somebody asked me to do
a show a couple times and he
was talking about me can i say
a pet peeve and i wanna know
if prep even i wanna know what
you're gonna say as well okay i'll
tell you my trifecta
huh
shut up suffered by man
i'm printing heads every two years
sexy you guys are them too hard
i wanna laugh too why can't you
enjoy what i'm enjoying la to say
the resident would say um i had
somebody approached me to do a show
a couple times and i told my
inward through my reps and i told
my reps i do want to do
this but i can't do it right
now
now and which was true and it
was like it was one of those
sort of right now who's want it
with sammy hagar it was one of
those trying to come down to cuba
homework shows where you have to have
a story you have to have whatever
else i was like i don't really
have anything right now but i like
the idea of the show i just
don't can't join anyone you like being
asked can i just say what it's
anytime anyone writes
do you and says it's so easy
all you have to yeah yeah the
sort of thing or or i will
have to do is come come two
successive nights well that's insane yeah watching
the thing i love that's like sometimes
it's really good but breezy but i
resent watching stuff because i've to watch
so much stuff for newcomers and i'm
like
the amount of things i watched their
homework yeah it's like yes too much
yeah thanks so much for being on
our teenage mutant choice so happy to
do it i loved it so one
of the guys that runs the show
after i think i said i said
not now i can't do it now
like for the second or third time
guy wrote to me directly it was
like
hey if you don't want to do
the show just say you don't wanna
do the show oh obnoxious yeah yeah
now you're like no i don't wanna
do the show exactly and i never
wrote back to him i was like
well here we go i'd burn naps
on that problem well so this is
my pet peeve is when i get
i get emails where i know someone
asked for an email from a mutual
friend or something but they don't explain
how
hey guys i didn't like hi this
person didn't even say who they're i
got one from this guy the other
day and he did not even say
who he is i looked up and
i was like i guess i've seen
that person around the story of screwdriver
exactly just had this happen to me
recently and he was like hi i
wanted to know if you would do
such and such and such and such
and it was a long email and
i wrote back and i said um
maybe but you'll have to forgive me
but how how do we know each
other who i've done that somebody gave
you my email and he just goes
no one i'm just a fan and
i go i'm not gonna do this
i just guessed what i think i
think saying nice on your favorite new
york seem to give a background of
how you got my email yeah and
how yeah
if we've met before you might because
to assume wow remember whoa what where
why when and how and it's not
even it's not a dick ish thing
it's like no you know you're reaching
to someone who might not remember you
you know that yeah once have been
in the same room and i think
you should do to anyone you've ever
met i actually know but i actually
i don't think it's bad to framework
rowers yeah overtly yeah do that like
ooh la-la la-la it never hurts to
over else coming on who you are
and how you know some place like
yes i think that it can help
you if you say hello i'm a
friend of your friend has a blog
that gave me a number you know
this person
used like the other people who are
gonna do the show as my way
to lure me in because i know
those people and i'm like shh i
don't know what this thing like that
weird movie you you got lower guys
that was the island of doctor moreau
easiest thing ever watch like one time
my sister and i we got invited
to this open house and
it was exciting because the house was
made entirely of gingerbread and candy yeah
and yeah went in yeah which tried
to eat us know what you in
the oven yeah how do you know
what yeah did i tell you this
raw vegan
um also if anyone asks me for
a friend's email contact information
i will with always ask the boys
always a friend always it's crazy to
give it away but there's maybe one
time when i was like i this
is this is i know this will
be okay if i pass this along
i will still give them a heads
up i asked you if i'd give
my public history ma which i like
of course would not be weird but
it's like i'm not even getting just
give it to her and have her
emailing you in
like jackasses like no the fuck is
this i don't want anyone to know
why their their listeners out there who
are so lonely and no emails them
and they we're so spoiled know i
mean i can hear how it would
sound like granny or email but usually
it's what do you want to work
for free that's the email you're saying
sadly it's presumptuous sort of thing like
without
softening it or making it seem like
friendly in anyway yeah it's kind of
assumption that is weird yeah huh assumption
assumption junction what's your launch and replaying
three-tier what's going looking up oh my
god i was a student in ah
i'm glad that you know schoolhouse rock
yeah that saturday morning cartoons he's
looking for someone he's looking for sam
while he's looking for some la helicopter
we have
yeah a little bit louder now a
little bit loud enough this afternoon there
was a time paul when every dance
you went to absolutely someone would play
that it was a staple here the
staples of my high school dances were
that song and um what i like
about you by the romantics oh let's
go to weekly that my old band
wow
zhang jim and that show starring christina
applegate and amanda bynes and christina applegate
no no married with children i think
it was called what i like about
you i've told you the christina applegate
story right and oh no i'm sure
have where she broke into the applegate
hotel to steal
what is it i'll just when i
was working attention over on over by
robert i told you about show changing
stories he's baggage che ga chin shit
docker bed i was in this doesn't
reflect poorly on me anyone ah i
was waiting on no matter what you
think
whoa was i twenty five just going
to prime you for the story i
come off looking good now i've just
been like this is not a story
about us we know what you mean
we're making fun of shit there's a
really great account on instagram called dumas
d u x m oai and it
is a celebrity gossip rag basically people
submit on instagram
all instagram stories and people submit anonymously
stories about celebrities being mean or nice
or whatever and it just like it's
so fun jesus yeah i've seen people
i know and good nice ones too
that's nice because then the people defend
like no no no that person super
nice i went i met them at
this place and they were doing this
and like well no this this was
a perfectly fine story it
wasn't like my stories about hillary swank
and chad lowe where they wouldn't tip
it was more in the vein yeah
people post about that stuff too it
was more in the they or a
brittany murphy who i used to wait
on all the time until i told
her that i saw her on a
show and and said you were really
good and then she never spoke to
me again but wow but ah or
the guy who created a sick
tom who when i told him i
was a writer he was like i'd
love to read your stuff and then
when i gave him my script he
never spoke to me again who names
dry up when he's still alive didn't
love to read it
but no i was waiting on i
was like twenty five and i was
waiting i loved her you stuff inhale
i was waiting on two men who
were like older i have no idea
how much older but they they were
great i they paid for their their
check and everything and as i was
leaving one of them goes hey
you know christina applegate
i go diem do i know who
she is or do i know or
personally he's like do you know who
she is from married with children and
i go yeah because she's my daughter
oh cool
yeah i'm chris applegate
he might have said applebee's come to
think of it christina applebees
my daughter's a founder of applebee's it
was why i made the shit outta
luck
ah are we doing three oh yes
we are all right what do we
got we got to fuck don't make
their hereditary noise yeah
we have a fun teacher
when it comes to us from josh
thank you josh
loyal
listen to every episode every episode over
this is called protest song one player
describes a problem in society that really
bugs them the less serious the better
oh the other two players then improvise
to activists delivering a p essay about
the importance of fighting that problem culminating
in a protest song about the problem
sung as a duet
i mean this is right up our
alley yes hell yeah it is let's
ah who's teaming up well we i
guess we are we're all teaming up
all you want to give lauren and
i the initial subject yes
here's the problem that it needs to
be addressed okay is got it men
okay spitting their gum into urinals okay
this is a real thing that happens
and i don't understand it it's disgusting
and overnight you're going to
start with the song hey this is
sarah mclaughlin that's the background music
men can live with them hey guys
okay wow okay live with you ah
why can't we live with you because
of one nasty little habit that's right
when you use our urinals what do
you do here at urinals city
you take that nasty little piece of
less susan come
can i just stop you for saying
yeah well this is unusual your tone
when you're saying nasty little nasty gum
was very central i'm sorry are you
you guys are on the same side
right yeah i'm paying for this psv
i know i know i'm just i'm
trying to help i'm i'm not the
director i know guy was another actor
i thought you guys would have had
this old work done i know i
don't roll a nasty lions okay yeah
it comes up yeah he's okay i
was wording yes alright
guys can't live with an action huh
easy guys can't live with them and
you can't live with them and why
is it because when you use our
urinals hey heard you know you're you're
an old city you do this one
thing you spit your
little nasty nasty nasty cum
into those urinals and leave it there
it builds up into a nasty mound
okay can i stop you that i
also like stuff that's the most disgusting
that's why are you in profit i'm
not i'm reading it i just want
my glasses ah folks i'm sorry this
is a very important issue and i'd
rather we haven't seriously are you talking
to the the viewer know youtube i
think it's time for the duet yeah
just got to the sol right i
think you've made your case we can
we can cut it together you got
enough
i think i've got enough to say
nasty enough to go you know hey
momma hey momma hey momma hey momma
momma who a mama what mama who
a mama don't spend your nasty little
game on me it's nasty don't switch
on nasty little gomo
knee shot dawn's pitcher don't spit ya
don't fit jack always bit joe nasty
little como me imo urine baby don't
spit your gum in my mouth ooh
ahh
these are the lyrics i'm just saying
yeah you wrote we should yeah i
should have i should have stuck it
out loud before i ran out over
the second draft we finished it
thank you very much it's so you
always say the end of a take
do you know that's how lorded i
edit our scenes where we do our
improv show yeah we did it i
finished it we've finished okay i was
calling you names gotta be watched universe
you love watching things that people are
on
hi guy you know a few i'm
good i'm da i'm going to are
gearing up to it
give us five dollars alright so now
now lower and we should do a
live freedom we should do a live
through them i do that would you
do that ah no alright alright use
atif
ooh he's salted you give us paula
i okay i'm paul
the p s a is for um
the p essay is for not cutting
people off in traffic for not cutting
people off and wait public service announcement
to not cut people off okay not
that more people should be cutting people
off in traffic no okay no okay
cars cars they have four wheels don't
think but we don't as human beings
no we don't we are blessed with
two legs and two arms and if
we're lucky we have fingers and toes
on those things in toes on those
we have two eyes and one heart
that's right
right so when you're driving use all
three of those use your two eyes
your one heart your genitalia probably varies
depending on what gender you are can
we stop for signature know keep going
no oh you like this i thought
that was great okay sure some of
you have pp some of you have
we we i didn't i didn't
okay i'm not sure why damage stopped
you there because pp and we are
both penises right well no i consider
the wee wee to be the fidget
percy for you i wasn't gonna say
my g the fudge
the fudgy sweet center
the fudgy sweet center of every lady
well i can throw all this out
if you want i actually whoa whoa
we're a team buddy way yeah just
throw stuff out you know what i
really appreciate what he knew just got
to the song alright really
we we haven't even really remember to
work and everything said we're talking exactly
it's it but the problem maybe the
song covers our cars penises vaginas i
think we get it huh okay let's
do it if you're driving down the
highway or on its urf a street
in someone's neighborhood then what happens when
someone cuts you off you really know
that they should not do don't got
people all figure ca daca people oh
you the dole god people off in
your car don't gotta people off where
you ah i'm gonna stop you right
there i don't like the idea of
pee pee wee wee
in that so okay let's you didn't
let's fish oh sorry we're getting into
the bridge hs okay yep go for
it and if he and if you
have a bb oh yeah oh we
we do well that's good vi you
because you can go both ways and
drag too so
on your screen name will be you
to pray oh thank you for being
afraid that was going on thank you
b yeah oh that was great thank
you thank you so much did it
so are you going to pay us
i will make good on the cons
trad
okay are all right your turn um
this is about um not
unloading the dishwasher when it's clean
okay that people should be doing that
people owning the dishwasher yeah people people
who don't unload the dishwasher and just
leave it for their spouse or significant
other right but butler kids kids kids
or spouses attention attention this concerns you
and a concern
earns us all as a d what
you're hearing is the alarm the dishwasher
wishes it could put out whenever you
leave the dishwasher loaded with clean dishes
when you leave the dishwasher load of
the clean dishes the dishwasher myers will
be saying my stomach hurt so dishwashers
basically filled itself up with ten
thousand clean eminem's and they're just sitting
in the middle of the stomach waiting
to be processed when we're another it's
like a torture the dick cheney would
be proud of you gotta get those
dishes out of there do it for
your dishwasher the dish that makes a
wish the dish that makes a wish
okay can i hear the song but
that the one request i have is
that the word dish and wish is
not in
in the song oh yeah is that
oh right does that go away oh
neither of those words neither of those
words okay but musically but how about
dishes part of dishwasher no i'm sorry
i just i mean we've focus tested
it in the lower station wish i
know i know i feel like i'm
about to cry okay but we focused
did it and people really find those
just the the vowels and consonants really
harsh yeah if you you squirted a
couple out so i guess yeah you
guessed yeah plates plates cups cups dishes
this fuck okay okay okay give us
another third give us another chance
alright one more chant plates okay well
ah plates plates dish oh that was
the second time okay that's strike two
i don't know we don't know who
said this time we got there three
strikes we go this time we go
dish oh okay shit guys i hate
to do this but any good
so yes i'm going oh yeah wow
did this happen turn on the cameras
no thank you
send it to your loved ones
he was one more chance why one
more chance
disha shoes a wishes let me out
let me let me
oh you know what i love it
yeah worked with del lie it was
just to lure you closer to me
suh over there
oh guy and that's how you play
protest song that's how we play fun
that was how we played it mandy
mandy
you guys chow the sun has gone
down in a podcast episode of three
dots literally has secretively on this episode
of freedom um that's gonna do it
for us for this episode it was
fun next episode while it lasted we're
gonna have the the incredible conclusion to
the meme trilogy oh and i think
if i really on the edge of
their seats so paul is going to
bring
those top seven yes in with him
yes and remember the great eminem trilogy
x was originally conceived as a synology
so yeah we will be doing will
be a prequel over the years yes
toby where we just eat think a
cow plan for yes will eat
hard candy shells with no chocolate in
them
absolutely we will become soldiers um at
three am usa on twitter please rate
and review and share the podcast you
stars oh we're glad you this we're
glad to be out there free in
the world it's night yeah we're so
glad we're back so please ah tell
a friend and thank you all for
listening and we'll see thank you for
being a friend mona
thank you thank you robin dish will
we be beat oh yeah by a
uh